[Music]
it's it's this moment right here where
I'm supposed to be like hello you know
suddenly everything's not as fun anymore
do you like when they do it hello hello
this is Pete Holmes
and I'm Matt burning her from the
National I've been seeing Berninger yeah
that's wrong burning her your song you
were a kindness has the lyric everything
is weird and we're always in danger do
you feel that way now sitting here in
the couch no it does feel weird but not
dangerous I don't know I'm not afraid of
that flinch soft hands there I do I've
never worked a day so to me the National
is everywhere
you guys are huge but I do notice that
you guys haven't ever had like a pop
radio smash our fans found us from word
of mouth and stuff but never from like
having a song write on the radio I think
I bet you could why don't we write a pop
song together
okay well def Punk this year won the
Grammy for best recording ret record
song yeah forget lucky
so I'm looking that one see what those
lyrics are like she's ever wanted to get
she's ever concerned I'm up all night to
get some she's up all night good fun for
good fun for good fun this feels like
something you'd read on the back but
that's but you are having to tell it
that's why it works it oh you're right
oh great so well let's let's it is a
great song so let's write a song like
that there they're talking about being
in the club and having fun so where are
we a club headphone that's who I've
messed with perfection we're in a club
having fun you might be the first one
okay
we're in a club having fun okay I don't
oh you're writing fun give me some room
oh yeah yum yum give me some rum can we
make it about a three-way that's good
all right
and don't don't mess with success what
other songs are about three ways lay
lady lay is it yeah yeah if you listen
behind behind the lyrics why would you
say it twice if there was another lay
lady my you two fella say I think of
Cincinnati I think of a chili dish
that's chili over spaghetti they call it
a three-way put some chili on he's got a
demo on Tom it's sexual and delicious
chili chili on my hot dog is how I play
come on girl Cincinnati three-way
spaghetti and cheese oh okay so throw
some chili on my Getty
' ghe TGIF that's a good you know they
have one in Africa yes so they go
Serengeti is mostly foster bring me with
a Yeti that's it let's get through with
my girl Anna yet it yeah and you think
he's abominable there's a funny thing to
say afterwards and she's like complain
we have the verse the first verse now we
need a chorus it's simple to the point a
little bit erotic but still accessible
to the tween market things just I'm
ready
[Music]
no good I guess we put you I mean it's
kind of breaking my heart how I'm ready
really as a good chorus for a pop song
I'm ready yeah you know like I can see
it like we'll sell it to Chevy I'd be
like the Impala I'm ready
they'll probably take out the yeah
actually Dickie stuff yeah we need
another one into the good we're young
and having fun just put down a bunch of
funds and young so you mind if I play
air guitar where we do this that makes
me feel more it makes me feel but in the
mode yeah yeah yeah I do that a lot what
I'm one of them when I'm writing so
maybe I shouldn't really no no do it I
don't want you beat air Pieta
then it doesn't look right it looks like
you're tickling two babies hello
children
uncle Matt's here well I'm happy and a
little nervous to play for the very
first time
Matt burning her from the National and
me our group which doesn't have a name
yet
playing our first head Yeti Yeti get
ready
[Music]
we're in a club having fun
yum yum gimme mo rum throw some chili on
my jet III where weather Yeti
get ready map sincerely thank you for
doing this thank you for doing this
write me if you guys don't know the
National go check them out you won't be
sorry there might absolute favorite band
in the world bands over now because this
is this is doing this band now I mean we
only have to split the money two ways
now right
[Applause]
[Music]